the Guardians of the Galaxy are gearing
of for one last ride in the MCU will
critics pump the brakes on this Blaze of
Glory so far the reactions have been
largely positive though some of a few
complaints after a complicated
production history Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 finally hits theaters on
May 5th 2023 bringing director James
Gunn's Marvel Cinematic Universe Space
Opera to a heartstring tugging
conclusion that centers around the
extremely tragic backstory of Bradley
Cooper's rocket me and my friends are
gonna go flying together
into the forever and beautiful sky now
that some people have already been able
to see the movie a little early eagerly
awaited First Reactions have started to
arrive fortunately for fans of the
series many of these first impressions
are nothing short of Stella but there
are also those who have spotted some
strain at the seams Stephen Weintraub of
collider was among those enamored by the
film praising the experience of seeing
the movie in IMAX and tweeting loved
Guardians of the Galaxy 3. James Gunn is
leaving Marvel with an exceptional last
film and this loaded with so many great
moments it's hard to pick my favorite
scene verges Charles pollium was
somewhat more critical finding that the
film leans a bit too much on the wrong
things he tweeted Guardians of the
Galaxy 3 is very pretty too jokey and
hinges on you still being rubbed up in
the emotional fervor of endgame which I
don't think a lot of people are your dad
threw off a magic cliff and she died and
then I lost my temper and nearly
destroyed half the universe a lot of
people have seen the movie early do seem
to have that emotional further though
Gunn's final work for the MCU has been a
long time I'm coming and more than one
first reaction specifically advise a
viewer to bring tissues because of the
sheer emotional impact for example Leo
Rydell of Geekly Gods infused on Twitter
emotional action-packed comedic and a
tone that delivers grab the tissues
cause damn there are some moments Man
rocket is the Man music choices great
per usual and VFX to liver had a blast
Andrew J Salazar of discussing film
agreed tweeting Guardians of the Galaxy
3 is the most heart and soul from any
MCU film in a long time at times it's
hard to believe that gun got away with
so much of this in the best way possible
you're going to need tissues but not for
the reasons you're expecting several
others like Mike Ryan of uprox and Sean
tajipur of nerdropolis also praised the
movie and the emotional punch it packs
while pop cult planet and MTV's Kristen
Maldonado credited volume 3 for
breathing new life in the genre tweeting
after so much superhero movie fatigue
Guardians of the Galaxy 3 is a
refreshing and unexpected joy to watch
even the critical First Impressions that
weren't entirely praised seemed to be
mostly positive about the film pointing
out individual issues rather than
outright lumbusting volume 3 as a whole
why trombone of inverse saw good things
in the movie but lamented its apparent
lack of stakes and the grander scheme of
things she tweeted Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 is the Star Trek Beyond of
the series in the best and not so best
ways but Gunn is really good at this
whole disarmingly Earnest superhero
Thing and even more so when he unleashes
his old trauma instincts wish it felt
less like a side quest though
and it is painful Alex Madden who
reviews films on YouTube felt the movie
couldn't quite deliver on the level the
very first Guardians of the Galaxy did
but still rated it above Volume 2
tweeting Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
takes a lot of big swings and mostly
delivers a couple hiccups here and there
but the clue that holds this movie
together is definitely rocket meanwhile
mans neglia of next best picture took a
harsher approach he praised the visuals
but said the rest was a mixed bag
tweeting Guardians of the Galaxy volume
3 aspires for sweeping emotion
gut-busting laughs and thrilling action
it sometimes succeeds but it's a
send-off for all of these characters it
feels strangely uneven and
anti-climactic it seems that the people
who enjoyed seeing Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 love it very very much and
even the ones who weren't quite so swept
away with it found plenty of good to go
with the bad
foreign